in this country has been issuing
warnings they've been saying that this
is coming and of course that draft
opinion which was leaked indicated that
this would happen that abortion rights
might be taken away in the coming days
and weeks they've been doing things
outreach programs they've been
encouraging
women to stop up on abortion pills these
are pills that you can take instead of
having a surgical abortion early on in a
pregnancy they've been mailing these
pills out to women across america
warning of this moment coming but its
full effect will only really be felt as
of today and in the coming days and
weeks when these laws are enacted in
states across america to restrict or
even ban abortion there are um just to
go into slightly some of the weeds of
this decision there are 13 states which
have so-called trigger laws
trigger laws mean that as soon as this
ruling is handed down or within 30 days
of this ruling being handed down as it
has been this morning these walls will
come into effect which severely restrict
or ban abortion this means women who are
pregnant in certain states places like
arkansas louisiana mississippi
who would have been able to have
abortions up to 15 weeks or beyond
yesterday will now turn up at an
abortion clinic and they will be forced
by law to turn those women away and i
think the full magnitude of this
decision will only be felt on the ground
by those women in the coming days
and weeks but certainly you can
see behind me the strength of feeling
here i think in the foreground you can
see
this lady who's on the loudspeaker
they are pro-choice campaigners so they
were in favor of seeing roe versus wade
maintained they believe that abortion is
standard healthcare and a human right
in the background
you have the pro-life campaigners who
are celebrating what they see as a
hard-fought victory the victory in
seeing roe versus wade overturned a
ruling that has stood for 50 years 50
years of legal precedent undone with one
decision
i'll just bring you the a small bit of
the dissenting opinion from three of the
supreme court judges they were three of
the judges that opposed the overturning
of roe versus wade they are pro choice
pro abortion if you like uh justices
bria sotomayor and kagan they said with
sorrow for this court but more for the
many millions of american women who have
today lost a fundamental constitutional
protection
we descent that gives you some
indication
of uh the their strength of feeling
over this issue president biden as well
as opposed to the overturning of roe
versus wade we expect to hear from him
um
in the coming
minutes and hours as this this decision
the magnitude of this decision
really sinks in with america but
certainly a hugely
consequential moment a seismic moment
for life and law in this country
it really is martha and we just want to
explain what's happening martha is
outside the supreme court in washington
d.c um a really emotive moment as the
u.s supreme court overturned that
50-year-old ruling roe versus wade a lot
of people demonstrating outside the
supreme court so we do apologize for any
um any profanities you may hear or any
profanities you may read on the signs
there um let's go back to martha um
who's outside as i said the supreme
court and martha there are these key
emotive issues aren't there in the us
gun law being one of them and this
abortion
[Applause]
yeah they call them the culture wars
here
and they're used as political calling
cards abortion never used to be a
political issue it was a religious issue
but many people on the pro-choice side
say it's been hijacked by republican
politicians to become an issue that will
bring voters to the polls and it's
clearly something that that many people
are very very exercised about in this
country
it's an issue which the evangelical
christians feel very strongly about
certainly and i spent quite a lot of
time in recent weeks really exploring
what abortion means to certain sections
in america for example
i was in
milwaukee in wisconsin
wisconsin is a state which will severely
restrict or even ban abortion
as of today i spent some time there with
pro-life or
anti-abortion campaigners and they were
saying that they don't even support
abortion in cases like rape and incest
and that's
the the issues that are particularly
emotive many people
wonder how you justify forcing a woman
to give birth to a baby that has been
conceived as a result of sexual violence
their response to me asking them about
that
was that two ones don't make a right and
that why should a baby be punished for
the sins of another that's just how
strongly people feel
about this issue and certainly in most
states most of these 25 or 26 states who
are set to restrict or severely ban
abortion there won't be exceptions
for rape or incest there will possibly
be the exceptions when the health of the
mother is at risk or when the baby
has shown signs of serious fetal
abnormalities so abnormalities that can
be detected in the womb but generally
this will be a blanket ban on abortion
in almost all in half or more of the
states in america
there are as i mentioned before 13
states which have enacted trigger laws
they include oklahoma
and texas they will ban abortion in the
coming hours and days it really does
happen
that quickly and three of those states
have nearly immediately effective dates
so they will happen today seven could
come into effect in a matter of hours or
days so you asked earlier
what is the strength of feeling about
this issue in america what i would
suspect is it's about to get a lot
stronger as this becomes a lot more real
for millions of women in this country
thank you so much we've had some a
couple of updates we're going to leave
martha there a lot for martha to get her
head around obviously a couple of
updates steve scalisi he's the house
republicans
republican whip he's tweeted he's just
written
life wins that's his response
kevin murphy the republican house leader
he's also tweeted and he has said every
unborn child is precious extraordinary
and worthy of protection i applaud this
historic ruling which will save
countless innocent lives the court is
right to return the power to protect the
unborn child the unborn to the people's
elected representatives in congress and
the states and obviously all of this is
in reaction to um the u.s supreme court
taking that
dramatic step
overturning that landmark ruling from
1973 roe versus wade um this is a live
shot outside the supreme court let's
have a listen and watch when the crowd
outside the supreme court heard that
they had overruled
that case
[Music]
[Applause]
so that was the moment that the crowds
outside the supreme court um heard that
the supreme court had overturned that
roe v wade ruling um obama barack obama
former president he's also just tweeted
he said
today the supreme court at barack obama
not only reversed nearly 50 years of
precedent
it relegated the most there you go the
most intensely personal decision
someone can make to the whims of
politicians and ideologues attacking the
essential freedoms
of millions of americans so that is the
latest uh barack obama there tweeting
his reaction to that um in the last
couple of minutes let's speak to carolyn
shapiro now she is um
a legal expert she's a professor um at
the chicago kent college of law
let's just go let's start with where we
are right now how have they overturned
a ruling from 1973
how do they have the power to do that
yeah the supreme court always has the
power to revisit its own opinions
especially in constitutional areas there
are some things that congress
can
change if congress wanted to pass a law
changing a statutory statute after it
disagrees with
a statutory interpretation it can do
that but when it comes to
interpreting the constitution
the supreme court at least as it has
been our system for a long time has has
the last word and can decide that it was
wrong in the past
okay and for people who don't know what
roe v wade is or was um can you just
set it out in layman's terms
sure in 1973 the supreme court held in
roe versus wade
that there is a constitutional right to
privacy that encompasses a woman's
decision about whether or not to carry a
pregnancy to term
it set out some parameters didn't say
that all and any abortion had to be
allowed there's some regulation and some
prohibitions were permitted
but that was the the gist of that
opinion in 1973.
that became very controversial very
quickly in the united states in 1992 the
supreme court revisited it in a case
called casey
in casey
people thought that it was very likely
the court would overrule roe vs wade but
in fact it did not in a joint opinion
issued by three
of republican appointed justices and
the courts held essentially that it was
going to keep the core of roe
intact
and since then there has continued to be
enormous controversy around this
recognized constitutional right and
today the court has expressly
uh overruled both roe and casey
eliminating any constitutional
protection
for abortion in the united states so
what does that mean on a state-by-state
level if you're an individual who wants
an abortion
in any state what happens now
it depends entirely on where you live if
you live in a state that has already
enacted what is called a trigger law
which is a law that was ready to go into
effect the moment that this opinion or
an opinion like it came out of reversing
roe
abortion is now illegal in your state
whether it is entirely illegal or
illegal only after some very early stage
of pregnancy uh is varies a little bit
from state to state but about half of
the states have such laws or have
otherwise passed laws more recently that
would make abortion
illegal or that even have laws that are
left over from before 1973 that are now
going back into effect so in about half
the states in the country maybe a
slightly more i believe abortion is as
of right now illegal
and why was the supreme court revisiting
it at this moment
this has been an incredibly
hot button issue in american politics
for decades
the republican party has consistently
run on a platform of appointing justices
who would overrule roe
donald trump certainly ran on that
platform quite expressly
and uh they've succeeded
why is it such a hot button issue
i think you would get a lot of different
answers to that question
you've asked um but i would say that
there are people in the us who believe
that uh a a fetus or an embryo
is a human being
entitled to
the protection of the law there are lots
of people in the united states who
believe that that it is not and it
cannot be treated as a full human being
at least until it is capable of survival
outside the mother's body
there's also a lot of research that's
been done on the way that conservative
the conservative movement and funders of
the conservative movement have tried to
use abortion
to rally the troops that it's been a
very deliberate attempt to use this
particular issue
to generate support for the republican
party
and in some cases perhaps somewhat
cynically
okay just quickly let's talk about the
makeup of the supreme court
because that is key here isn't it
it is absolutely key
right now there are six justices on the
supreme court who were appointed by
republican presidents and three who were
appointed by democratic presidents those
three justices
dissented the chief justice chief
justice roberts who was appointed by
republican president george w bush
wrote a concurrence in the judgment i
believe and i have to say i have not had
time to really study this opinion yet so
uh but i believe he wrote a concurrence
in the judgment saying what people
expected him to say which was that he
would have upheld the law in at issue
which outlawed abortion from 15 weeks on
but wouldn't have gone as far as the
rest of the court did the other five
justices have voted to completely
overrule roe and casey
three of those justices were appointed
by donald trump justice gorsuch who was
the
replace justice scalia was the was the
justice that
the nomination that
the seat that president obama had
actually appointed nominated somebody to
but the senate refused to consider
um justice kavanaugh
um who people your viewers may recall
was confirmed after an extremely ugly
confirmation battle that involved
uh un under-investigated
allegations of sexual assault when he
was younger
and uh justice barrett who replaced
justice ginsburg
a well-known feminist strong pro-choice
uh
justice who died
less than
two months before the 2020 election and
who
donald trump and the republican senate
rushed through it's also worth noting
that
quite a few of these justices have were
appointed
by a president who did not receive a
majority of the american
of the popular vote in the united states
and were confirmed by senates
by its votes in the senate that did not
represent anywhere close to a majority
of the american people now that our
constitution allows that so that's not
unconstitutional
but it certainly raises questions about
how these such a controversial decision
will be received by americans okay
carolyn shapiro professor at chicago
kent college of law thanks a lot stay
with us we'll come back to you for the
meantime though let's go back to our u.s
correspondent martha calendar who's
outside the supreme court uh mother i'm
sure a lot of people they're just trying
to take in what's just happened
they certainly are and just to pick up
on a point that your your guests your
previous guest was making
there there are 59
of americans favored keeping row versus
wade in place so this supreme court
these nine judges or at least six of
them are out of step with public opinion
and just to reflect on the magnitude of
this this is a seismic moment for
america a constitutional right has never
been
removed in this way 50 years of legal
precedent undone
overnight to the disgust it has to be
said of many of the pro-choice
campaigners those who favor abortion
here
i'm joined by this lady sorry what's
your name my name is julian julie and
julie's dressed up as a clinic escort
just explain what the clinic escorts do
in clinics across america
so we are partnered with
women's healthcare providers um mostly
planned parenthood but we of course have
other ones and we escort women into the
clinics um
in front of the protesters that are
there to scream obscenities at them
possibly sometimes they can get violent
and just japanese in
general so we um just bring them through
and pass all the
people and sometimes it can get very
rowdy out there
how does today feel for
you it's been a little bit time coming
here we have expected it but um
i am still heartbroken
for all the women that this is going to
affect and for all the women especially
in marginalized communities especially
in black communities that will die
because of this decision today
many
pro-choice campaigners like yourself
are concerned as you touched on there
about the fact that this could drive
women underground to get abortions that
this could result in what they used to
call back alley procedures are you
concerned about this that this puts
women's health at risk 100 that's
exactly what's going to happen i know
that there are already plans for the
underground um there are you know there
are
the lawmakers are trying to even
criminalize the women that transport the
women that need the procedures so they
are trying to criminalize anything you
can't get them out of state you can't
get them in that's what they want but
right now no we are organizing of course
and back alley abortions will definitely
start up again and more women will die
they'll go into sepsis
and they'll die from without abortions
when you talk about uh
helping women and doing outreach now
what does that involve
it involves me getting back to work when
i get home because like i mentioned
there will be women lining up um you
know to get our health care so
whereabouts you from charlotte north
carolina so north carolina is still a
legal state and it will remain a legal
state as long as we have our governor
and
that's all we can do right now all i can
do is get back to work keep working keep
pressing people to go out and vote for
the right people that will get this back
on track because they are very organized
they did this in 50 years is not a long
time for this kind of thing to happen
and
as you see the numbers today i'd like
them to be a lot bigger than they are
right now
some of us also feel that because it was
released in january it made it seem like
the anger has died out so we need to
reignite that or nothing will be done
thank you very much julie julie there
was touching on how this is such a
divisive
issue in states like hers north carolina
abortion will remain legal it is almost
divided exactly down republican and
democrat lines so when you see that that
map on election night and it glows up
red and blue it's generally the red
states which will severely restrict or
even ban abortion while it will remain
legal in the blue state so states like
new york and california have said that
they intend to become what they call a
safe haven for women seeking abortion
they say that women will be welcomed
from across state lines to receive what
they call
abortion health healthcare and it's
divisive not in terms of geography but
as julie was saying it's also
divisive that divided down class and
race lines so it's generally the poorest
women in those red states who won't be
able to afford to take the time off work
and to travel across state lines to
receive abortion healthcare which will
who will be
most disproportionately affected i'm
just going to to walk a little bit
further into uh this melee of people
outside the supreme court they've been
hit people
waiting here
for weeks for this decision the supreme
court hand down their decisions at 10
a.m
on decision day but we didn't know that
this decision was going to arrive today
so i'd imagine uh as as the days
progress and the hours progress
apologies that we'll see more and more
people gathering here i'm just trying to
to find someone from the pro
life side the side that opposes uh
abortion if we can find someone to speak
to
we've also just had the politician
marjorie taylor green
down here celebrating saying that this
ruling was a blessing
from god i'm just going to pray for all
those on the other side you disagree
with me can i can i just speak to you
about your um
hey martha i'm going to jump in there
and let you find some more people to
speak to because we're getting response
now on twitter have a look at this this
is senator elizabeth warren she's just
tweeted six radical supreme court
justices have overturned nearly 50 years
of precedent stripping away the
constitutional right to an abortion
after decades of scheming republican
politicians have finally forced their
unpopular agenda on the rest of america
and she goes on there elizabeth warren
tweeting her response there a lot of
people um
tweeting this is interesting this is
nicholas sturgeon have a look at what
she's just tweeted one of the darkest
days for women's rights in my lifetime
obviously the immediate consequences
will be suffered by women in the u.s but
this will embolden anti-abortion and
anti-women forces in other countries too
solidarity doesn't
feel enough right now but it is
necessary let's speak to jessica mason
piccolo she's a former lawyer and now
supreme court journalist
jessica thanks so much for joining us
i'd just like to get your reaction to
that ruling by the supreme court
uh this is a dark day in the united
states for our constitution as you've
already noted no time in our history has
the supreme court ever taken away
a fundamental constitutional right and
in such an egregiously anti-democratic
fashion
as they did today
i think it's really important to dive
into some of the details of what
happened because what folks need to
understand is that this is a campaign
that does not stop with abortion
justice clarence thomas in his
concurring opinion specifically asked
for the court to revisit other privacy
precedents because that's what we're
talking about here is the right to
privacy other privacy precedents
including the right to same-sex marriage
the right to birth control and the right
to engage in same-sex relationships at
all
so
this country is headed down a radical
path when it comes to rewriting our
understanding of individual privacy
jessica just just talk to us and explain
to us why you think it's undemocratic
because a lot of folk will be watching
and will think actually it's not that's
how the system works it worked it's just
not in the way you wanted it to work
right
sure though that's a fair point and i
think you know some of your other guests
have already um detailed in some pretty
good fashion just how
um off the rails and outside the norms
this current supreme court is operating
so let's set aside the fact that three
of the most recent supreme court
nominees were were appointed by a
president who is under active
investigation in this country for
seditious treason
that is something that should give
everybody pause we know that there were
significant dark money campaigns to put
those justices on board on the court and
that should also give people pause but
more importantly when you look at the
way people in this country vote
in the places where they can vote in
those states that haven't gerrymandered
their right to vote away
overwhelmingly support the right to
abortion in this country what the
supreme court did today was craft an
anti-majoritarian rule and it wasn't
just an abortion they did this yesterday
in the decision to overturn a new york
guns case that was a hundred years on
the books they are acting with power
because in the system that we have in
this country
they can go unchecked
yeah that is basically because the way
the supreme court is set up and how they
get onto the supreme court right
correct these are lifetime appointments
and at this point the only remedy to
remove the justice is impeachment and
that's a political process
and that requires political will and
what we haven't seen in this country is
the political will to do that despite
the fact that we have two justices who
have been credibly accused of sexual
assault on the supreme court one justice
whose wife is actively involved in the
insurrection investigation in this
country and yet folks are sitting on
their hands so i would no longer say
look to the united states as the beacon
that it once maybe was
it's interesting because mitch mcconnell
has just tweeted
and he has said the supreme court ruling
is courageous and correct and it's a
historic victory for the constitution
and for the most vulnerable in our
society
yeah i'm not surprised that that that's
mitch mcconnell's reaction and what
folks need to understand is in this
country there has been a campaign to
politicize the court with appointees who
would do this kind of thing you know the
case that the supreme court ruled on
today
got there in a very unusual fashion
normally there has to be some kind of
fight in the lower courts about whether
a law like the mississippi law was
unconstitutional there was no fight
because all of the courts who had looked
at this decision at this law before had
said this is completely unconstitutional
it is clear that under roe and casey it
is unconstitutional and we have no power
as the lower courts to overturn roe
versus wade and planned parenthood
versus casey the supreme court sat on
this case for 13 times it conferenced on
this case for over a dozen times and
they didn't decide to take it until amy
coney barrett was appointed to the
supreme court
and the 6-3 ruling so it's interesting
isn't it that elizabeth warren has come
out and said what does she say six
radical supreme court justices have
overturned nearly 50 years of precedent
yeah
we have never had a moment like this in
this country's history and if that is
not the definition of radical i don't
know what it is so what happens now who
are the people who are going to be most
affected
by this immediately
immediately abortion is now illegal in
over half this country and that's how is
that just explain yeah just explain that
to us if you don't mind jessica
yeah so uh 26 states currently have laws
on their books that go into effect
either immediately or as a result of a
functional administrative process that
now bans abortion you know places like
missouri arkansas louisiana for example
like and and those are
large places states with a lot of people
in them we know immediately this is
going to the impact the most vulnerable
populations but it will impact all of us
at some time because the reality is
there is no way to enforce an abortion
ban without making all pregnancies
suspicious we already have a trend in
this country of starting to prosecute in
jail women for failed pregnancy outcomes
oklahoma did it we have a woman in
oklahoma who is in prison for a
miscarriage at 14 weeks that's not even
a viable pregnancy
so if you think that because you live in
a state that currently protects abortion
you are protected you're not you are now
under excessive state surveillance if
you have the ability to become pregnant
hillary clinton has just tweeted can we
bring that tweet up she said um
there you go most americans believe the
decision to have a child is one of the
most sacred decisions there is in that
such decisions should remain between
patients and their doctors
today's supreme court opinion will live
in infamy as a step backward for women's
rights and human rights let's go back to
jessica so hillary clinton weighing in
there as so many people are but jessica
there are a lot of people in your
country who believe that abortion is a
bad thing and it shouldn't be legal
um they represent a vocal minority in
this country okay just talk us through
that how can something go through the
supreme court be overruled
a court case that's 50 what 1973 that's
just been overturned by the supreme
court and you you're saying to us that
it's a
minority of people in the country who
believe that abortion should be illegal
yeah it's not just me you can look at
any poll and that is conducted on this
issue a majority of americans you not
unanimously overwhelmingly since the roe
vs wade decision support the right to
legal abortion how is it that this
country is in this place because the
anti-abortion movement has made this a
political cause of theirs for nearly 50
years they pivoted away from school
segregation when it was no longer
popular to be openly racist in the
united states they moved to abortion as
a way for political momentum that's what
they did during the reagan years in this
country and it accelerated in the bush
years and then it went on steroids
during the trump administration they
gerrymandered state legislatures they
the mississippi bill that passed isn't
even written by legislatures in
mississippi it was written by a
conservative advocacy organization
called americans united for life so
lawmakers aren't even writing these own
bills that's what's going on in this
country
okay jessica thank you so much for
talking to us and giving us your time
has been really interesting thanks a lot
thank you so much thanks jessica okay
straight back to uh our correspondent
martha kellner she's outside the supreme
court amata you've just been getting
more reaction from people outside the
court there
i have before we get started on that i
just want to touch on what i think is
one of the most shocking sections of uh
this opinion so when the judges the
supreme court judges handed down this
this decision they write what's called
an opinion um which is a fairly lengthy
description of why they've arrived at
this decision
when i spoke to senator elizabeth warren
after the draft opinion um was after the
draft opinion was leaked last month she
said she feared that this could open at
the door for other constitutional rights
to be challenged constitutional rights
which are also protected like abortion
by the notion of privacy they are rights
like the right to contraception um and
to same-sex marriage well it seems that
the fears that she had the fears that
are shared by many people across america
are warranted because
in this opinion one of the judges
clarence thomas
writes the supreme court should
reconsider griswold lawrence and
obergefell
the rulings that now protect
contraception
same-sex relationships and same sex
marriage in that statement clarence
thomas is opening the door for other
constitutional
rights to be challenged and so this
really is a seismic
moment i think now we can hear from the
speaker of the house nancy pelosi and
her reaction to this decision
to make
[Music]
their own health decisions
because of donald trump mitch mcconnell
and the republican party their super
majority in the supreme court
american women today have less freedom
than their mothers
with
roe their attempt to destroy it radical
republicans are charging ahead with
their crusade
to criminalize
health freedom
in the congress
be aware of this the republicans are
plotting a nationwide abortion ban
they cannot be allowed to have a
majority in the congress
to do that
but that's their goal
and if you read
and again we're all studying all this
but you read what is in the
very clear
one of the justices had his own
statement
it's about
contraception in vitro fertilization
family planning
that is all what will spring
from their decision that they made today
such a contradiction
yesterday to say the states
cannot make laws governing
the constitutional right to bear arms
and today
they're saying the exact reverse
that the states can overturn
a constitutional right for 50 years a
constitutional right
for a woman having the right to choose
the hypocrisy is raging
but the harm
is endless
what this means to women is such an
insult
it's a slap in the face to women about
using their own judgment
to make their own decisions
about their reproductive freedom
and again it goes well i always have
said the termination of a pregnancy is
just their opening act it's just their
front game but because but beyond
behind it and for years i have seen in
this congress opposition to any family
planning domestic
or global
when we have had those discussions and
those debates and those votes on the
floor of the house
this is deadly serious
but we are not going to let this pass
a woman's right to choose
reproductive freedom
is on the ballot in november
we cannot allow them
to take charge so that they can
institute their goal
which is to criminalize
reproductive freedom
to criminalize it
right now they're saying in states that
they can arrest doctors and all the rest
what is happening here
what is happening here a woman's
fundamental health decisions are her own
to make in consultation with her doctor
her faith her family
not some right-wing politicians
that donald trump and mitch mcconnell
pack the court with
while republicans seek to punish and
control women democrats will keep
fighting ferociously to enshrine roe v
wade
into law of the land
this cruel ruling is outrageous and
heart-wrenching
but make no mistake
again
it's all on the ballot in november
the supreme court has ended a
constitutional right this is
50 years
proclaimed a constitutional right
what happened today was historic in many
respects
historic in that
it had
not granted
recognized a constitutional right and
then reversed it
this is a first
and again
just before it imposed a constitutional
right to
allow for concealed weapons
how about those justices coming before
the senators and saying that they
they respected
sorry decisive the president of the
court
that they respected the right of privacy
in the constitution of the united states
did you hear that
were they not telling the truth then
again
just getting to the gun issue because
really
in preparation for this morning i was
really an exalted state about what
happened in the united states
senate yesterday
counterpoint
to the dangerous decision of
this trumpian supreme court that they
made yesterday
but a way to take us to as the bill is
called community safety
the bipartisan safer communities act
right now and i'm going to have to leave
momentarily because we just finished
voting on the rule
we will be debating the bill
on the floor
and we expect a good bipartisan vote on
it in the house we congratulate the
senate on the work that they have done
and the timeliness of it to be passed in
the senate in a strong bipartisan way on
a day
when the court
made such a dangerous dangerous decision
we will
many of our house democrats proposals
that are included in this package
are that keep deadly weapons out of
dangerous hands by encouraging states to
establish extreme risk protection order
laws
erpo otherwise known as red flag laws
help put into straw purchases close the
boyfriend loophole
so many good things are in there and
it's not everything that we wanted we
must keep moving toward background
checks but
universal background checks which will
save the most lots but this will save
lives
and to listen to lucy mcgrath and other
family members of those who have lost
their loved ones
this is a giant step forward
maybe not so much a giant but a strong
step
forward and if it's good enough for them
then we rejoice in passing it
as i say to members all the time okay
we're going to leave nancy pelosi there
speaker of the house um she's in dc
we're going to go to kigali and hear
from um
horrors of the 20th century
in recent memory and now finds itself
with a thriving social and economic life
and near universal primary education
today rwanda is hosting leaders
representing two-thirds of the world's
population stretching from the remotest
islands of the pacific